australians are fighting back against
their country's draconian stay-at-home
lockdown policies so the australian
government is fighting back against them
firing rubber bullets into crowds
chasing them back into their homes and
forcing them to obey the public health
police
the scenes are startling if we saw these
images in some far-flung third world
country afghanistan or venezuela the
liberal establishment would be calling
for regime change but when it comes to
australia
our regime is on the same side as the
public health enforcers maybe it's time
for some regime change at home i'm
michael knowles and this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from gregory williams
who says 52 of americans
are uh not of the opinion that joe biden
is not sound enough to be president
because they know that kamala is less
competent that is a very good answer i
asked i said how is it that only 48 of
americans think biden is not fit to be
president well
because the other 52 are looking at
kamala harris you make a very good point
you know this
is the sort of time where we need to
protect our way of life we got to
protect our liberties we've got to
protect the first right of ours which is
the right to life which is why i would
recommend you check out 40 days for life
abortion is coming up a lot these days
it's in all the newspapers it's about to
be a much bigger topic when the supreme
court rules on the most important
pro-life case since roe versus wade or
at least since planned parenthood v
casey you're going to want
the best arguments you're going to want
all the facts 40 days for life has the
perfect book for you if you're looking
to arm yourself against a broad range of
pro-abortion talking points the book is
called what to say when the complete new
guide to discussing abortion this book
is an easy read for individuals looking
to defend life and convert hearts a lot
has changed since abortion was legalized
in 1973 what to say when equips readers
with proven approaches to dismantling
the pro-abortion agenda
these methods have already enabled 40
days for life to convert the hearts of
221 abortion workers it's pretty amazing
check it out right now what to say when
the complete new guide to discussing
abortion how to change minds and convert
hearts in a brave new world get free
shipping and 21 office signed hardback
at 40daysforlife.com
what to say when what's going on in
australia right now
is absolutely insane
if you have seen the scenes i mean you
know we just play that very tiny little
bit of the of the cops rushing and
shooting rubber bullets into the crowd
chasing everyone away they now have a
stay-at-home policy they're trying to
to covid zero which is not possible
covet zero meaning not a single person
even has coronavirus that's not going to
happen which means that the public
health dictatorship is going to continue
on at infinitum
why is this happening
some people are saying well we're
misinterpreting the science or some
people are saying well it's because the
the unvaccinated are not cooperating we
could all have our freedoms if we just
gave up some of our freedoms
the real reason that this is going on
right now
is very simple it has to do with
religion
all regimes
have something to do with religion okay
they have some religious foundation you
look at a place like afghanistan the
religious foundation
is islam
okay no matter what exact government
comes and goes islam is going to be the
basis of it in the west and in america
in particular that grounding originally
was
christianity
right now over time
in america the religion became the civic
religion of say the founding fathers or
of abraham lincoln this is why
on our national mall we have a
greco-roman temple with a giant statue
of abraham lincoln as if he were zeus
okay this is why we have weird
obelisks to the deities of our founding
fathers like like george washington
because it is a civic religion and we at
least until very recently worshipped the
values that they stood for and worshiped
these men as sort of demigods now now
we're tearing down their statues and
replacing it with a new religion now the
new religion is even more secularized
than the one that we've been laboring
under for a long time it is the cult of
science there is a band that i had never
heard of called the kaiser chiefs this
is an english indie rock band the lead
singer is ricky wilson he was just at a
concert full of all sorts of people
they've got their hands in the air and
he says that's right put your hands in
the air not hands in the air to feel the
music not hands in the air to feel the
spirit hands in the air to show me how
clean you are because you've gotten your
vaccine
there are clean hands
washing them
let me hear it if you've had the vaccine
[Applause]
yeah you've got clean hands i can see
it's good
we're spraying it with jello man
all right follow us
that's right they're now calling him not
the kaiser chiefs but the pfizer chiefs
this is really creepy stuff
and it doesn't make any sense unless you
are familiar with religious ritual it's
a sort of religious ritual right with a
great many religious rituals you you
undertake a ritual purification so you
know that you're broken you know that
you're fallen you know that you're
impure but then you go through this
ritual purification and then you are
pure again right and then you go go out
into the world and so this has become a
literal
uh ritual
you know it's not just that you're
cleansing your soul though that's part
of it with this but you're you're
cleansing your body because we live in
this very secular age
and by cleansing your body you cleanse
your soul this is why the anti-vaxxers
are being booed this is why they're
being jeered this is why they're called
deplorable and awful and murderers right
that they're guilty of some sort of
sin some metaphysical crime if they do
not take the fouchyache and then they're
not clean
really
creepy stuff
but this sort of thing is going to be
inevitable your your society is going to
have some religion or another and if you
don't have
true good normal religion then you're
gonna have creepy weird modern science
religion but you're gonna have some
religion and it's
not very scientific in the sense that
many of these supposedly scientific
health measures we're undertaking are
actually killing a lot of people there's
a study out of the uk right now
which is that
it's showing that uh
10 000 unnecessary deaths
just from cancer
will result from the lockdown
this is because a lack of
door-to-door visits you know a lack of
actual in-person visits a lot of
treatment for you know perfectly
treatable illnesses
is going to result from people locking
down everything saying stay at home the
only issue is this wu flu
all that matters is the chinese cough
and if you've got cancer
if you've got other procedures that
you've got to undertake
forget about it it doesn't matter
according to this university college
london survey
and study an estimated 40 000 people
since last march of uh since march of
last year
were referred to emergency care for
cancer late
which conservatively means 10 000
britons will die significantly earlier
than under normal circumstances and the
possibility of excess deaths could be
several times higher in the worst-case
scenario but if if we save just one life
it will have been worth it if we save
just one life
of one person who didn't catch any germs
that will have been worth the 10 to 40
000
excess deaths of people from cancer in
great britain right doesn't make a lot
of sense but
when you when you think of the world in
this very utilitarian kind of way
you end up making these ghastly sort of
calculations rather than beginning from
principles of justice how should we live
is this ordered is this virtuous is this
just to live in abject servile fear of a
little wuhan cough
to lock down take people's property take
people's lives away
no of course not of course that's not
just but when you're making these really
clinical scientific calculations of well
if we lock down we'll save this one life
then you end up in these ghastly sort of
calculations which you're seeing right
now actually in the pages of the
washington post there is a very sad
column that just came out from uma
thurman terrific actress uma thurman
who is attacking the pro-life law in
texas
and she's saying it's a human rights
crisis for american women and to make
her case she's coming out with news that
people did not know before which is
that she had an abortion she said she
started her acting career at 15 and she
was accidentally impregnated by a much
older man
she doesn't say she was
raped exactly she accidentally
impregnated and
she was in living out of a suitcase in
europe far from her family about to
start a job
she struggled to know what to do i
wanted to keep the baby
but how
so she calls home there's problems at
home
the the family decided quote i couldn't
go through with the pregnancy and agreed
that termination was the right choice
my heart was broken nonetheless
okay
there's so much pain in this story she
writes it's been my darkest secret until
now i'm 51 years old i'm sharing it with
you from the home where i've raised my
three children who are my pride and joy
the abortion i had as a teenager was the
hardest decision of my life one that
caused me anguish then and that saddens
me even now but it was the path to the
life full of joy and love that i've
experienced choosing not to keep that
early pregnancy allowed me to grow up
and become the mother i wanted and
needed to be
so the obvious question that comes from
this
why was it so sad why does it sadden you
even now why did it break your heart
because
you killed your child that's why and
a lot of women do it and a lot of women
don't know what they're doing at the
time and especially if you're 15 years
old you might be very confused
especially if your family is telling you
to kill this child especially if the
whole culture is telling you to kill
this child but deep down you know what
it is and you know that that gnaws at
you and that's deeply saddening and
especially in a world that doesn't
recognize the possibility of redemption
this is going to eat away at you forever
and ever of course she didn't need to
kill a baby she could have given the
baby up for adoption there are many many
couples who want to adopt children many
more couples who want to adopt little
babies than little babies who are put up
for adoption but then listen to this
line she goes
she says uh you know the the life full
of joy and love that i've experienced
was caused
and it was enabled because i had this
abortion you heard this from another
actress some years ago i forget her name
she said i won this gold statue because
i had an abortion i couldn't have done
it if i hadn't had an abortion
sacrificing your children to gold idols
is nothing new that is actually the
default state of human nature and
judaism you know the ancient israelites
and then christianity in in its
fulfillment come about and say don't do
that stop doing that okay
we are now reverting to that society is
going to have some religion or another
which one do you want to have do you
want to have the religion that seems a
little kooky with the smells and the
bells and the crucifixes and the little
liturgies or do you want to have the
religion that is much kookier where the
high priests are people like dr fauci
and where the high sacraments are child
sacrifice which which you're going to
have some religion which one do you want
to live under
when you want to see things
clearly and without eye strain i would
strongly recommend you check out blue
blocks if you're anything like me you
spend a lot of your life staring at a
screen
and whether you notice it or not
that the blue light from that screen is
causing damage to your eyes it leads to
digital eye strain it can lead to
headaches blurred vision watery eyes
i've noticed this since i was a kid for
some people it could even cause
heightened anxiety depression and low
energy
blue blocks is here to fix it they have
high quality lenses for daytime
nighttime and for color therapy exactly
in line with the suggested peer-reviewed
academic literature
they got over 40 very cool-looking
frames come in prescription
non-prescription and readers
they've got frames for every single need
blue blocks is also giving back by
working in partnership with restoring
vision in their buy one gift one program
so for each pair of blue blocks glasses
purchased they donate a pair of reading
glasses to someone in need i do not look
at a screen anymore if i'm getting blue
light coming out seriously it's
a huge improvement go to blueblocks.com
use promo code noel's at checkout get 20
off and enjoy free shipping on orders
over 115 bucks get your energy back
sleep better block out the unhealthy
effects of blue light
blublox.com knowles click the link below
make sure you use the code canon wlas to
get 20 off your order enjoy free
shipping on orders over 115 bucks
b-l-u-b-l-o-x dot com slash knowles for
20 off today
we are now at the anniversary of
the late supreme court justice ruth
bader ginsburg's death remember our the
notorious rbg she was the last hope and
then she died and trump was able to fill
her vacancy and this is very sad she was
an icon
on the left people wear t-shirts of her
and make movies about her they pretend
that she was the first woman supreme
court justice even though she wasn't it
was sandra day o'connor who was
appointed by reagan but everyone forgets
about that
so
in honor of rbg people are posting a lot
of quotes of hers today
but even though rbg only died one year
ago even though she was a leftist icon
she wasn't radical enough
so
other leftist groups now are editing her
quotes this is from the aclu aclu posts
a tweet says with justice ruth bader
ginsburg's death we lost a champion for
abortion and gender equality and on the
anniversary of her death the fight to
protect abortion access
is more urgent than ever now here's the
quote
the decision whether or not to bear a
child is central to a then they insert
these brackets
persons life
to brackets their well-being and dignity
when the government controls that
decision for brackets people
brackets they are being treated as less
than a fully adult human responsible for
brackets their own choices do you see
what they did here
it's not they're not too subtle about it
what rbg originally said was the
decision whether or not to bear a child
is central to a woman's life to her
well-being and dignity when the
government controls that decision for
women
for women or a woman this woman is being
treated as less than a fully adult human
responsible for her own choices
now of course the quote is ghastly and
hideous and untrue
killing your own child is not central to
your freedom and your life and your
dignity
if you're a woman
but
the the left has become so radical that
they're not even allowed to acknowledge
that abortion is a woman's issue
now
the the aspect of this that i think
people are missing here
as we all joke about how even rbg now is
a conservative compared to the aclu and
these other leftist groups invoking her
is that
the
radicalism of the new gender pronouns
and the transgender movement
was
actually being promoted by the feminists
like ruth ginsburg
when ruth ginsberg says a woman needs to
be able to kill her baby to be free she
is setting the stage for transgenderism
because what she's saying is women and
men need to be exactly the same women
and men are not exactly the same because
women uniquely can bear children
and because of that that implies certain
responsibilities and a certain sort of
role for them that men don't have so we
need to be able to
remove that that role that distinction
even if it means killing your own child
and that way men and women can be equal
but when men and women can be equal and
there's no such thing as women anymore
we're all just some kind of blob and so
the very words
woman she
hers are cut out of of rbg's quotation
speaking of disrespecting women
you probably haven't heard this story
right now coming out of wisconsin
because the establishment media don't
want to cover it but you recall
in the last few weeks
we lifted a lot of afghans
out of that country as it felt at the
taliban we left a lot of americans there
but we took a lot of afghans out and
these afghans
these afghans are more american than any
american they are as american as apple
pie they were all translators that
country man chock full of translators
and we had it was our duty to lift them
out of the country
frankly they're a whole lot more
american than the insurrectionists
and the and the mega trump
deplorable people and so they land in
wisconsin
and now they're raping children and uh
beating their wives this from the
journal sentinel two afghan refugees
charged with child sex and spousal abuse
crimes at fort mccoy
barula nori who's a 20 year old afghan
evacuee
is being charged with attempting to
engage in a sexual act with a minor
using force against that person along
with three other counts of engaging in a
sex act with a minor according to wqow
and then 32 year old muhammad haroon
imad is being charged with assaulting
his wife by choking and suffocating her
on september 17th this is at fort mccoy
this is at the refugee camp
this is under the watchful gaze of our
authorities the first thing these guys
did when they landed in america
is rape kids and beat their wives and
choke them
now i'm not saying that all afghan
refugees do this
but i am saying
maybe we didn't vet these guys so well
we know we didn't vet these guys so well
because there's very little vetting
going on here in the united states they
were told that all the vetting was done
by the state department before they left
but we know there was no vetting being
done before they left either people were
clinging to the to the wheels of these
airplanes
turns out cultural differences might
actually persist turns out that
different cultures worshiping different
gods engaging in different rituals and
mores might live differently
and that you can't contrary to what the
liberal
globalist establishment has been telling
us for a very long time now
you can't just drop any person from
anywhere in the world into the united
states and have them instantly become an
american and when you when you
discourage assimilation they may very
well never become an american
likewise you cannot just drop the
american bill of rights
the constitution or the declaration into
some godforsaken backwater
and just assume that that's going to
transform the country overnight
contrary to what george bush told us at
the second inaugural not every person on
earth is yearning for 19th century
english enlightenment ideals of
self-government it just doesn't that it
just isn't true
it doesn't
exist
and it raises this other question by the
way
the same left that is insisting that we
flood the country with foreign nationals
is the left
telling us
that we are the worst country in the
world evil racist bigoted
violent
in maxine waters words trying to bring
the country back to slavery days as she
accused america of of doing when border
patrol agents were caught attempting to
do their job we're saying to the
president and everybody else you got to
stop this madness
and i want to know in the first place
who's paying these cowboys to do this
work they've got to be gotten rid of
they've gotten to be stopped it cannot
go on and so i thank all of you for
being here today write the story
tell the story
about what is going on and let people
know that they're trying to take us back
to slavery days and worse than that
here we go it's another day it's another
democrat invoking slavery i mean i would
attack maxine waters here
she is a really loathsome member of
congress i mean she she called for
physical violence against republicans
and has done that repeatedly throughout
her career
you get on them when you see them in
public you get in their face you push
back on them you say they're not welcome
you remember that that whole thing she's
done it for many many years
but joe biden says the same stuff about
slavery he said it about mitt romney
who's a big lib he said mitt romney
wants to put you all back in chains when
he's talking to a mostly black audience
so
this is what they do they say look
america's defining feature is slavery
even though it existed here for less
time than virtually anywhere else on the
face of the earth
yeah and in a lower degree by the way no
that's america's defining feature and
it's never changed and we're still
living in the slavery days we're about
to go back it's about to get even worse
so this this raises this question
the gravel institute which is uh named
after uh senator mike revell he was a
radical left senator actually kind of
got a kick out of him
so some kids uh in his name founded the
gravel institute they wanted it to be a
kind of answer to prageru on the right
and it hasn't really worked out but they
still tweet sometimes and so they
tweeted out quote the united states
should accept at least 100 000 afghan
refugees
are you insane
do you
do are you racist do you hate afghans
you're telling me you want to take a
hundred thousand poor afghans who have
been through so much already
and then you want to bring them to this
evil racist bigoted unjust
hellscape
oh my gosh how much punishment do these
people need to endure
this awful country
you want to bring them no way i you know
what gravel institute i can't believe it
i'm going to have to go more left-wing
than you are right now i am calling for
a complete moratorium on any refugees
from anywhere in the world coming here
to this awful racist evil country
they have suffered enough okay
and they do not deserve to be brought to
suffer so much more in this evil rotten
racist place
so i'm listen gravel institute
listen
left wingers calling for more refugees
i i heard you i heard you the first time
when you said this is a terrible country
so i absolutely
i want to go to the logical conclusion
of your arguments and say no thank you
no
more did you i mean maxine waters said
the other day our border patrol was
whipping people
i mean they didn't have whips
and they weren't and they weren't
whipping people and they were just
riding horses with rains and they don't
know what the rains are but it looked
better look what just the appearance of
it
doesn't look good keep keep those
foreign nationals out of here
when you want to make sure that you're
supporting good old americans who ride
horses or good old american ranchers i
recommend you check out
good ranchers did you know that 80 of
the grass-fed beef that is sold in the
u.s is actually imported from overseas
maybe it'll say local farm but it'll be
a local farm in guatemala or something
it will not be it's not actually from
the u.s so good ranchers has gone out
and they have supported the american
rancher the american consumer and the
american
economy by finding the top-tier kind of
meat we're talking t-bones fillets
strips gourmet burgers which i love the
burgers are absolutely magnificent
better than organic chicken
they will give you that steakhouse
quality you deserve at a price every
family can afford go to goodranchers.com
knowles right now save 20 bucks or
better yet subscribe and save on each
box of mouth-watering american meats
that will show up right on schedule
right to your door get 20 bucks off
right now and free express shipping if
you go to goodranchers.com knowles or
use code knowles at checkout 20 bucks
off and free express shipping at
goodranchers.com
knowles subscribe and start listening to
morning wire on apple spotify or
wherever you listen to podcasts leave a
five-star review if you like what you
hear we'll be right back with a lot more
the liberal blue checks are at it again
they always are
one of them he's a twitter activist
named brooklyn dad defiant
he is really harping on this complete
canard this lie
that border patrol agents went out like
indiana jones with whips and just
started whipping you know haitian
migrants as they were coming across the
border
which by the way
like they didn't do that
but
i'm not saying use whips but i do think
you should enforce the law if people are
pouring into your country illegally you
should stop them from doing that
you should enforce the law but they
didn't they didn't have whips and they
were not doing that so this twitter blue
check says quote slavery must continue
to be taught in schools but especially
the parts about how slaves were beaten
and whipped to death so you can see us
react strongly to similar scenes
and you can
s that you can shut the f up with your
quote actually those aren't whips
they're reigns
so this guy's acknowledging he's like
they're they're not whips you're right
we lied about that but don't it doesn't
matter
that might not be true but it gets to a
greater truth that's the sort of thing
the left always says when they get
called out on their lies they say well
sure that thing wasn't true but it it's
about a greater truth what's a great
it's all a bunch of lies and then you
put all your lies together and you get a
truth i don't think i i'm no
mathematician but i don't think that's
how arithmetic works
but what what's so ironic here is
he's saying he's suggesting that we're
not going to teach slavery in schools
anymore this has been another line of
the left they're saying that critical
race theory just means teaching about
the history of slavery it's
not even close to that critical race
theory is a very specific marxist
academic movement that was developed in
the late 20th century and has only
really started infiltrating colleges in
recent decades the history of slavery
has always been taught but i love that a
guy like this
who is admitting
that his side does not know the
difference between a whip and reins for
your horses he's saying we should be in
charge of education
we don't we don't know the difference
between
very basic tools
but we want to run education in america
that doesn't make a lot of sense to me
this is actually one of the
few silver linings to the storm cloud of
the year and a half plus of lockdowns
is that
kids are pouring out of public schools
into charter schools and home schools a
new report from the national alliance
for public charter schools revealed that
charter school enrollment grew
7.1
during the 2020-2021 school year that's
the largest expansion in half a decade
nearly a quarter million new students
enrolled in innovative student-centered
charter schools despite a sharp increase
in
a sharp decrease in overall public
school enrollment during the same period
so the overall public school enrollment
goes down but the charter schools go way
up
of the 42 states evaluated 39
experienced charter school enrollment
increases
only three states saw modest decreases
by comparison direct
you know sort of public school district
school enrollment during that same
period dropped precipitously in every
single state
in certain states oklahoma and alabama
charter school enrollment grew
77.7 and 65.1 percent respectively even
in lib states like oregon enrollment
grew over 20
on top of that which is great news for
the charter schools on top of that
homeschooling between march 2020 and
september 2020 homeschooling grew
between 5.4 and 11
throughout the country and in some other
cases by the way we're not even counting
here the private schools that parents
send their kids to this is very
important
this is very important
it's going to accelerate a trend that
you've been seeing for
decades now around the country which is
the collapse of a common culture
the common culture of tv we don't all
watch the same tv shows anymore the
common culture of movies we barely watch
the movies anymore the common culture of
schooling
we're not going to have that
quite as much anymore
that would be a bad thing if we had a
healthy culture that's a very good thing
if we have a very unhealthy culture if
the common culture
becomes poisoned
and tells us that our country's evil and
you're evil and if you're white you're
irredeemably evil and
you know the founding fathers are evil
if the
if the common culture that educates and
raises us and creates our citizens
is is poisoning
our people
then you got to crack that common
culture and that is very good news
speaking of those old days of a common
culture speaking of common tv shows
did you watch the wonder years growing
up i did i watched it in reruns but i i
watched it
great old show about growing up in the
60s and suburbia
kevin and winnie you remember that so
the wonder years
is getting a reboot just like every
other show and just like every other
movie
they're they're getting a reboot
and now
the family is black
that's the that's the big twist
not only is it a reboot but you see it's
a re and the family is black
this is evidence of a dead culture not
because black people shouldn't be on tv
shows but because
of the reboot of it with the kind of
political twist
that's the evidence of the dead culture
the reboot is the main thing though
ghost but there's ghostbusters
ghostbusters is a great movie and
there's more ghostbusters movies and
they're not as good but they're fine
and then they're going to reboot
ghostbusters okay well all right can't
you think of any new ideas no okay so
you're gonna reboot it you're gonna just
do it again
but this time it's with women
oh okay well that's not
all right
why
well yeah it's with you're not just
gonna make a new movie with women you're
gonna make your own reboot ghostbusters
you're redo ghostbusters with women yeah
that's what we're gonna do because we
have no ideas but we're also really
political and really into identity
politics okay
and so we're gonna reboot the wonder
years but the family is black but hold
on i thought you i thought the whole
point was
that the experiences of white people and
black people in america are radically
different isn't that what the left has
been telling me for years and especially
oh my goodness especially in the 1960s i
thought the experiences were totally
different totally incomparable
well well okay maybe maybe what they're
gonna do here is make the entire
experience of the show totally different
from what it was for the white people in
the wonder years okay well then why are
you calling it the wonder years then
it's not a reboot then it's
are we just so out of ideas are we so
both out of ideas and ginned up by
identity politics that this is our
culture now
well then it's not a culture it's just a
it's just
digging up the old corpses of the past
and trying to reanimate them like
zombies they don't only do this on the
left we do this on the right too
when when people constantly just quote
ronald reagan
that that would be an example of this
ronald reagan was
last president in
january of 1989.
he's been dead for a good many years now
he's been out of public life since the
early 90s
let him lie he's a good guy i like i
have a great admiration for ronald
reagan
now we have to do our things we need to
enact our political vision we need to
pass our laws we need to make our tv
shows we need to make our movies but we
can't
we don't we seem to just be kind of dead
and decadent as a culture speaking of
things that are dead
i got to talk about jeffrey epstein
is he dead i don't know actually i
suppose that's more of an open question
he didn't kill himself did he die at all
i don't know
jeffrey epstein was friends with very
wealthy very famous
very influential people
one of whom is bill gates
and bill gates has never really answered
for his close association with jeffrey
epstein
so bill gates was on pbs newshour
he was asked about jeffrey epstein
and he got extremely nervous
and he sort of started sort of fidgeting
and dancing around the question and
repeating himself probably lines that
were written up by some crisis
communications expert
and then he gave probably the spookiest
answer you probably could about his his
thoughts on jeffrey epstein with
hindsight
those meetings were were a mistake they
didn't result in
uh what he purported and i cut them off
you know that goes back a long
time ago now uh there's you know so
there's nothing new on that it was
reported that you continue to meet with
him over several years
um
and that in other words a number of
meetings um
what did you do when you found out about
his background
well
you know i said i regretted having those
dinners uh
and there's nothing absolutely nothing
new on that is there a lesson for you
for
anyone else looking looking at this
well he's dead so
uh
you know in general you always have to
be careful uh
and you know the
you know i'm i'm
very proud of what we've done in
philanthropy very proud of the work of
the foundation
uh
you know
that's
that's what i get up every day and focus
on so i know we've all been joking about
how hillary killed jeffrey epstein
but uh
i'm beginning to rethink that uh do you
have excuse me mr gates mr one of the
richest guys in the world most
influential guys for many decades
do you have any lessons that you have
learned or that you think other people
should learn from the jeffrey epstein
experience
well
he's dead so
wonder if you got that lesson everybody
when you implicate old billy in a crime
well things don't turn out very well now
i'm not i'm not saying
that bill gates killed jeffrey epstein
i'm not saying it bill i'm not please
please man i got a family please don't
but that is
that is the level of hubris from our
ruling class i'm i'm really not saying
that jeffrey jeffrey epstein was
murdered viciously by bill gates in a
prison cell in new york i'm not saying
that
what i am pointing out is
bill gates
did not learn a thing
he's making excuses he's downplaying the
relationship which was fairly extensive
he's trying to deflect he's uttering the
same old lines that some crisis pr guy
told him
and
and then
the nearest thing he has to a lesson
that he's learned is that well he's dead
problems gone
no hugging no learning it's like the old
seinfeld maxim no hugging no we didn't
learn a thing
i'm gonna keep doing whatever i want not
changing my mind but maybe maybe the
people i associate with aren't so savory
maybe some of the initiatives i'm
involved in are a little creepy maybe
maybe i should have uh some humility and
not try to rule the entire world bill
gates this is a man
who has dedicated his philanthropic
career to
making sure there are fewer black people
being born in africa is to
overpopulation
and to
i guess becoming the the chief medical
expert in the world on coronavirus bill
gates who has the exact same
epidemiology degree that i do namely nun
bill gates a man of incredible
hubris and a really hideous political
vision you really see it with the
overpopulation stuff this idea that
there need to be fewer people and
especially fewer black people and
especially fewer poor black people in
africa
there's just so many of them they might
breathe too much and and anger the sun
monster and then he'll send his evil his
his punishment of global warming upon us
and then we won't be able to have as
nice a time on our yacht because it'll
be a little too hot on the on the
sundeck
you know we can't we can't be having
that
more abortion for africa
he doesn't see it that way he doesn't
recognize
i don't think
that all of these ideas all of these
political regimes have a religious
foundation so he doesn't he doesn't
recognize the significance of his
obsession notably with overpopulation
and and if if that statement is to be
believed he the only overpopulation he's
really focused on is the
overpopulation of jeffrey epstein still
existing you know well he's dead
no i'm kidding i'm kidding
please i'm kidding speaking of very
wealthy people hunter biden
is about to become even wealthier than
he already is you know there was that
that video that he himself recorded that
was found on one of the many laptops of
his that he let get stolen
where he said that he makes like a
gazillion dollars you know and he makes
all this money by selling his father's
influence and selling out the united
states to ukrainian oligarchs and
chinese oligarchs
so
hunter biden
is now an artist he's not a very good
artist but he's an artist i say this i'm
a
fairly untalented amateur painter myself
i took it up during kovid and i am
freaking caravaggio compared to hunter
biden i'm really not good you know i'm
just like copying things on youtube but
i am titian i am michelangelo compared
to joe biden's derelict son so hunter
biden's gallerist josh belgie
he has just said that hunter's paintings
could sell for half a million bucks
which should put hunter biden a person
with no artistic training or talent in
the very top tier of emerging artists
according to artnet
the thing that
sticks out to me here and what what
relates to the bill gates story is not
even just the hubris
it's
there's not not even just the money it's
it's it's this this idea that they can
do whatever they want
okay this idea that there is no
consequence yeah i'm gonna peddle my
dad's influence i'm gonna make millions
of dollars doing it
come and get me yeah i'm gonna paddle
around with jeffrey epstein i'm never
gonna answer for it come and get me no b
what are you going to do to me
yeah we can be wrong about everything
what are you going to do
you're going to do nothing because no
matter how transparently corrupt we are
we got the power and you don't
speaking of the corruption of our
governments
you remember we were told
the coronavirus is a hundred percent
naturally occurring it has nothing to do
with the wuhan institute of virology
which is right where it was discovered
and it has nothing to do with gain and
function research and it didn't leak
from a lab
and how dare you conspiracy theorists
suggest that this isn't perfectly normal
and occurring in bats
then we found out no it actually not
probably
i probably did escape from that lab in
some way and no it actually was involved
in gain of function research and
actually the united states was involved
in gain of function research and
actually everything that dr fauci and
all the rest of them told us was a lie
so now we're finding out new bombshell
report from the telegraph
scientists at the wuhan institute of
virology including british zoologist
peter dazak of eco health alliance
were reportedly planning to release
quote
enhanced airborne coronaviruses into
chinese bat populations to inoculate
them in the months before the covid
pandemic
the scientists also sought funding from
the united states to create chimeric
viruses which are quote genetically
enhanced to infect humans more easily
these were revealed in leaked grant
proposals dating back to 2018
which a former a u.s official has
confirmed as being authentic
according to the telegraph
they did it
they lied about it
they were more involved in it than even
many people speculated they were and now
they're not going to face
any repercussions whatsoever when dr
fauci was asked about the gain of
function research and our involvement
with wuhan institute he perjured himself
senator rand paul is now trying to bring
him up to some consequences on that
won't matter
it will not happen they have the power
and we do not the republican governors
right now
they want to at least seem like they're
doing something on immigration
you know this historic flood of foreign
nationals
pouring across our borders so what are
they doing
they wrote a strongly worded letter to
joe biden i'm not joking
here we go all but one gop governor in
the united states signed a joint letter
to joe biden demanding a crackdown on
the flood of illegal immigration coming
across the southern border
great
great i'm glad the one gop governor is
the one in vermont he's not he's
obviously not going to sign it they're
big hippies over there so that's it the
best we've got is dear joe biden please
stop
uncle uncle that's what that's basically
the libs and the the establishment
has our hand twisted up behind our backs
they're pulling it up toward our neck
and the best that we can do to stop them
is yell uncle please stop please stop
they're not going to stop they're not
going to stop unless we amass political
power and then actually wield it which
very few people seem to want to do now
on the topic of wielding political power
you may have heard of this story of
gabby petito who was a youtuber
and uh it she was murdered
and it appears that she was murdered by
her boyfriend it's not totally clear but
it kind of seems that way so this is a
you know a
scintillating story it's very sad story
and it's got all these elements of kind
of true crime and personal interest but
as a political matter it doesn't doesn't
matter that much for the national
political scene
well everyone's obsessed with this story
governor ron desantis has just ordered
state agencies to look for this guy the
boyfriend who's on the lamb who
definitely looks like he killed his
girlfriend
the the only political aspect of this
now
is
libs
politicizing
the focus on the story so
you've got uh buzzfeed
which is coming out and saying
here is everything we know about lauren
cho and daniel robinson two missing
person cases brought to light by the
disappearance of gabby potito and
lauren cho and daniel robinson are
people of color and you see what what
the gabby potito story tells you is that
we don't put enough focus the media does
not focus enough on people of color they
only focus on cute little white girls
they've been so we don't know enough
about lauren cho and daniel robinson
there are many many other people
obviously who have gone missing and this
is absolutely awful because america's so
racist why won't the media do this joy
reid
who is the sort of left-wing tucker
carlson
without the charm or intellect
or rigor she's on msnbc or ratings for
that matter uh
joy reid goes on msnbc and castigates
the media for focusing on this white
woman who was viciously murdered and not
talking about people of color
the way this story has captivated the
nation has many wondering why not the
same media attention when people of
color go missing well the answer
actually has a name missing white woman
syndrome the term coined by the late and
great gwen eiffel to describe the media
and public fascination with missing
white women like lacey peterson or
natalie holloway while ignoring cases
involving missing people of color
yeah it's awful that the media if the
media are focusing on these white people
you know they're not in white women
specifically the media i mean i hate
that media the media they're they're not
focusing on black people i hate that
conservative media that conservative
right-wing trump supporting oh wait a
minute the libs control the whole media
joy you're the media buzzfeed you're the
media you're the media
you are the whole media i know i have a
show it's very nice i appreciate the
many people who listen to the show i
know
ben and dan bongino and tucker carlson
they they have shows too and they reach
you know especially tucker gosh tucker
reaches a few million people a night
that's it
the country's 330 million people
the biggest show on the right reaches
what three maybe four million people
at that at the height
the libs control the whole
thing the whole media joy reed could
talk about it she doesn't need to
jewelry doesn't need to talk about gabby
potato but she's choosing to
buzzfeed doesn't need to
now they complain and this is what they
do
they
rule with incompetence mendacity
they rule in this really vicious way
and then
when everything goes wrong who do they
blame do they take the blame themselves
no they blame you
they blame you or they just move on or
both
that's what they do
that's
our
regime
that's the people who are shooting
rubber bullets and australian citizens
that's the people calling you deplorable
and irredeemable and bible thumping
bitter clinging rubes that's the regime
the cause of they create the crisis they
create the problem
they blame you for the problem
then they grab more power to solve the
problem they don't solve it they make it
worse rinse and repeat i'm michael
knowles the michael knowles shall see
you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
ben shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there